selamat kembali ke Understanding Quantum Information and Computation, nama saya John Watrous dan saya Pengarah Teknikal untuk Pendidikan di IBM Quantum
ini adalah pelajaran ke-13 dalam siri ini dan ia adalah pelajaran pertama dalam unit keempat dan terakhir iaitu mengenai ralat kuantum
pembetulan Pengkomputeran Kuantum berpotensi untuk membolehkan penyelesaian yang cekap kepada tugasan pengkomputeran yang mana
algoritma klasikal yang cekap tidak diketahui dan mungkin tidak wujud namun terdapat cabaran yang sangat ketara yang
perlu diatasi jika kita ingin melaksanakan pengkomputeran kuantum berskala besar yang kita harap akan menjadi kenyataan suatu hari nanti
inti permasalahannya ialah maklumat kuantum amat rapuh kamu boleh merosakkannya hanya dengan
melihat padanya dan oleh itu untuk beroperasi dengan betul komputer kuantum perlu mengasingkan maklumat kuantum yang mereka
simpan daripada persekitaran di sekeliling mereka pada tahap yang melampau tetapi pada masa yang sama komputer kuantum itu sendiri mesti memberikan kita
kawalan yang sangat tepat ke atas maklumat Kuantum ini dan itu termasuk permulaan yang betul, operasi unitari yang tepat dan boleh dipercayai
dan tentu saja kemampuan untuk membuat pengukuran supaya kita boleh mendapatkan keputusan sebenar daripada
pengkomputeran ini jelas ada ketegangan antara keperluan-keperluan ini dan pada zaman awal Pengkomputeran Kuantum ada sesetengah pihak yang melihat bahawa kerapuhan
maklumat kuantum dan kerentanannya terhadap ketidaktepatan dan hingar persekitaran akan akhirnya
menjadikan Pengkomputeran Kuantum mustahil hari ini hampir tidak ada keraguan bahawa membina komputer kuantum berskala besar yang tepat dan boleh dipercayai
adalah cabaran yang sangat besar tapi kita ada satu alat utama untuk membantu kita dalam usaha ini yang menyebabkan kebanyakan
orang yang tahu tentang bidang ini optimis bahawa Pengkomputeran Kuantum berskala besar suatu hari nanti akan menjadi kenyataan dan alat itu adalah pembetulan ralat kuantum
untuk empat pelajaran seterusnya kita akan membincangkan pembetulan ralat kuantum dengan fokus pada
asas-asasnya dalam pelajaran ini kita akan melihat pertama kali pembetulan ralat kuantum termasuk salah satu daripada kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang pertama
yang ditemui iaitu kod Shore 9 qubit dan kita juga akan membincangkan satu lagi Konsep asas dalam
pembetulan ralat kuantum yang dikenali sebagai pendiskritan ralat dalam pelajaran berikutnya dalam unit ini kita akan melihat pembinaan kod
pembetulan ralat Kuantum yang lebih canggih dan akhirnya lebih baik dan kita juga akan membincangkan masalah pengkomputeran kuantum pada maklumat Kuantum yang dikodkan menggunakan
komponen pengkomputeran yang sendirinya tidak sempurna dan terdedah kepada ralat ini adalah gambaran ringkas
pelajaran kita akan mulakan dengan membincangkan kod pengulangan klasikal yang mungkin merupakan jenis yang paling mudah dan paling asas
kod pembetulan ralat klasikal kod pengulangan klasikal bukan kod yang sangat bagus mengikut piawaian
Teori Pengekodan Klasikal sekurang-kurangnya secara tersendiri tapi tak apa di sini kita utamakan kesederhanaan dan khususnya
kita akan melihat kod pembetulan ralat klasikal yang paling mudah yang boleh kamu bayangkan yang kemudiannya akan kita gunakan sebagai asas untuk contoh mudah
bagi sebuah kod pembetulan ralat Kuantum contoh itu adalah kod Shore 9 qubit yang akan kita bincangkan secara terperinci
termasuk penerangan tentang kod itu sendiri serta prosedur untuk mengkodkan qubit menggunakan kod ini mengesan ralat pada qubit yang dikodkan dan
membetulkan ralat tersebut dan dalam bahagian ketiga pelajaran kita akan membincangkan pendiskritan Ralat yang membolehkan kita memikirkan tentang ralat sewenang-wenangnya pada
qubit yang pada dasarnya membentuk suatu kontinum kemungkinan dalam istilah diskrit iaitu pada asasnya menyederhanakan ralat kepada
apa yang dipanggil bit flip dan phase flip sebelum kita masuk ke dalam perincian teknikal pembetulan ralat kuantum ia
berbaloi untuk sejenak mempertimbangkan keperluan untuk pembetulan ralat Kuantum serta pembetulan ralat klasikal
seperti yang saya cadangkan pada permulaan pelajaran komputer kuantum amat terdedah kepada ralat disebabkan oleh
kerapuhan maklumat kuantum khususnya interaksi yang tidak diingini dengan persekitaran atau dengan kata lain
baki dunia boleh mengganggu maklumat Kuantum interaksi yang tidak diingini ini boleh menyebabkan dekoherensi di mana maklumat
pada asasnya bocor ke dalam persekitaran menyebabkan maklumat yang disimpan oleh komputer kuantum berkelakuan semakin
klasikal juga amat penting kita sedar bahawa operasi Kuantum hanya boleh dilakukan dengan ketepatan yang terhad
sebagai contoh kita mungkin ingin melakukan gate kuantum tertentu pada sebuah qubit tetapi kerana peranti fizikal tidak pernah
sempurna apa yang sebenarnya kita laksanakan mungkin hanyalah penghampiran kepada gate itu mungkin itu bukan masalah besar untuk
satu gate tapi jika niat kita adalah untuk melakukan ribuan atau jutaan gate kuantum ketidaktepatan kecil ini akan
mula terkumpul dan apabila pengkomputeran selesai kita mungkin berakhir dengan keadaan yang sangat berbeza daripada apa yang kita
jangkakan jadi ini adalah sumber ralat yang agak berbeza tapi ia memang satu yang tidak boleh kita
abaikan orang telah mengkaji kod pembetulan ralat klasikal hampir satu abad dan kod-kod ini mempunyai banyak aplikasi termasuk dalam
penghantaran dan penyimpanan maklumat tapi kerana komponen Pengkomputeran klasikal sangat boleh dipercayai kita sebenarnya tidak
memerlukan pembetulan ralat untuk membina komputer klasikal kini mungkin sahaja pembetulan ralat sebenarnya tidak diperlukan
untuk membina komputer kuantum berskala besar yang boleh dipercayai juga sebagai contoh idea utama di sebalik
Pengkomputeran Kuantum Topologi ialah mungkin boleh membina sistem Kuantum yang kukuh yang secara intrinsik dilindungi daripada hingar disebabkan
sifat topologi sistem tersebut tapi kita tidak tahu sama ada ini akan mungkin dan ia agak meluas dipercayai bahawa
pembetulan ralat mungkin akan menjadi penting dalam satu bentuk atau yang lain untuk Pengkomputeran Kuantum berskala besar kini kita akan membincangkan kod
pengulangan klasikal yang membentuk asas bagi kod pembetulan ralat Kuantum pertama kita iaitu kod Shore 9 qubit yang
akan kita lihat tidak lama lagi kod pengulangan adalah contoh yang sangat asas bagi kod pembetulan ralat
ideanya ialah kita boleh melindungi bit daripada ralat dengan hanya mengulang setiap bit beberapa kali khususnya mari kita lihat
kod pengulangan tiga-bit di sini kita mengkodkan satu bit kepada tiga dengan hanya mengulang bit sebanyak tiga kali jadi
sifar dikodkan sebagai 000 dan satu dikodkan sebagai 111 sudah tentu jika tiada yang salah kita boleh
membezakan kedua-dua kemungkinan dengan mudah tapi jika ada ralat dan salah satu bit terbalik katakanlah
yang bermaksud sifar bertukar menjadi satu atau satu bertukar menjadi sifar maka kita masih boleh mengetahui bit asal
dengan melihat nilai binari mana yang muncul dua kali secara setara kita boleh nyahkod dengan mengira nilai majoriti
atau dengan kata lain nilai binari yang paling kerap muncul dan tidak susah untuk kita lihat bahawa
jika kita ada paling banyak satu ralat bit flip maka penyahkodan akan betul sudah tentu jika dua bit terbalik atau jika
ketiga-tiga bit terbalik maka ia tidak akan berjaya dan kita akan mendapat nilai yang salah semasa penyahkodan dan itu adalah sifat umum
yang dimiliki setiap kod pembetulan ralat kamu mungkin boleh membetulkan sesetengah ralat tapi kamu tidak akan pernah dapat membetulkan setiap ralat dan pada akhirnya ia adalah
tentang mengurangkan peluang ralat berbanding menjamin ketepatan yang umumnya tidak mungkin
WEBVTT
sebagai contoh situasi di mana kita boleh mengurangkan peluang membuat ralat katakanlah
matlamat kita adalah untuk menyampaikan satu bit kepada penerima hipotetikal dan untuk melakukan ini kita boleh menghantar bit melalui sebuah
saluran yang dikenali sebagai binary symmetric channel yang membalikkan setiap bit yang dihantar melaluinya secara bebas dengan sejumlah kebarangkalian
P jadi dengan kebarangkalian 1 tolak P penerima akan mendapat bit yang kita ingin hantar tapi dengan kebarangkalian P
bit terbalik dan penerima mendapat nilai bertentangan dengan apa yang kita hantar jadi jika kita tidak menggunakan kod pengulangan
dan sebaliknya kita hanya menghantar bit yang kita fikirkan melalui saluran penerima akan mendapat bit yang salah dengan
kebarangkalian p sebaliknya jika kita terlebih dahulu mengkodkan bit yang ingin kita hantar menggunakan kod pengulangan tiga-bit dan
kemudian menghantar setiap satu daripada tiga bit pengekodan melalui saluran maka setiap satunya terbalik dengan kebarangkalian P jadi
peluang bit flip kini lebih besar kerana terdapat tiga bit yang mungkin terbalik bukannya satu
tapi jika paling banyak satu daripada bit terbalik maka penerima akan dapat menyahkod dengan betul jadi kita hanya akan mendapat ralat selepas
penyahkodan jika dua atau lebih bit terbalik semasa penghantaran dan tidak terlalu susah untuk mengira bahawa ini berlaku dengan
kebarangkalian 3 kali P kuasa 2 tolak 2 kali P kuasa 3 untuk nilai P yang lebih kecil daripada 1 per 2
ini membawa kepada penurunan kebarangkalian penerima mendapat bit yang salah masih akan ada peluang ralat dalam kes ini tapi
kod itu mengurangkan kemungkinan ini dan jika kamu ingin mengurangkan peluang lebih lagi kamu boleh melakukan itu menggunakan
kod yang berbeza termasuk tetapi tidak terhad kepada kemungkinan menggunakan kod pengulangan di mana bit yang dikodkan diulang
lebih daripada tiga kali untuk nilai P yang lebih besar daripada 1 per 2 ngomong-ngomong kod itu sebenarnya memburukkan
keadaan dalam erti kata ia meningkatkan kemungkinan penerima mendapat bit yang salah jadi kita tentu tidak akan menggunakan kod ini dalam situasi itu
kod pengulangan tiga-bit adalah kod pembetulan ralat klasikal tapi kita boleh juga mempertimbangkan apa yang berlaku jika kita cuba
menggunakannya untuk melindungi qubit daripada ralat ia bukan kod pembetulan ralat Kuantum yang sangat baik seperti yang akan kita lihat ia
boleh membetulkan sesetengah ralat tapi ia menjadikan ralat lain lebih mungkin ia adalah walau bagaimanapun langkah pertama ke arah kod Shore
jadi mari kita lihat cara kerjanya untuk qubit pertama sekali supaya jelas apabila kita merujuk kepada kod pengulangan 3-bit yang digunakan
untuk qubit apa yang kita maksudkan adalah pengekodan satu qubit seperti yang ditunjukkan pada skrin di mana Alpha 0 tambah beta 1 adalah
dikodkan sebagai Alpha 000 tambah beta 111 atau dengan kata lain keadaan asas standard
diulang tiga kali perhatikan khususnya ini bukan perkara yang sama dengan mengulang keadaan kuantum tiga kali seperti dalam keadaan
Kuantum s dikodkan sebagai s tensor s tensor s yang bukan pengekodan yang kita akan dapat
laksanakan untuk Keadaan Kuantum s yang tidak diketahui oleh teorem no-cloning pengekodan yang kita perkatakan
sebaliknya adalah sangat mudah dilaksanakan ini adalah litar kuantum yang sangat mudah yang melakukannya menggunakan dua workspace qubit yang dimulakan dan dua
gate controlled-NOT kini katakanlah ralat berlaku selepas pengekodan telah
dilakukan dan khususnya katakanlah operasi polyx atau dengan kata lain bit flip berlaku pada salah satu
daripada qubit dan dalam gambar ini ia adalah qubit tengah sudah tentu ini bukan satu-satunya jenis ralat yang boleh berlaku dan kamu mungkin
membantah idea bahawa ralat mengambil bentuk operasi unitari sempurna ini tapi kita akan kembali kepada ini kemudian dalam pelajaran dan buat masa ini kita boleh
fikirkan ia sahaja sebagai contoh ini adalah Keadaan yang terhasil ia sama seperti pengekodan asal kecuali
bahawa bit tengah dalam setiap ket telah dibalikkan jelas kita boleh melihat ini daripada ungkapan matematik untuk keadaan itu
tapi andaikan kita hanya ada tiga qubit dan kita syak bahawa bit flip mungkin berlaku tapi kita tidak tahu qubit mana yang mungkin
terjejas satu cara untuk mengetahui sama ada bit flip berlaku ialah melakukan pengukuran asas standard dan memeriksa hasilnya dalam kes ini kita akan lihat
sama ada 010 atau 110 dengan kebarangkalian bergantung pada Alpha dan beta dan dalam kedua-dua kes kesimpulan kita
adalah bahawa bit tengah terbalik tapi malangnya itu merosakkan Keadaan Kuantum asal dan keadaan ini
mungkin sangat berharga bagi kita lagipun itulah seluruh tujuannya untuk melindungi keadaan Kuantum ini jadi ini bukan pilihan yang baik
apa yang boleh kita lakukan sebagai gantinya adalah menggunakan litar kuantum yang ditunjukkan di sini pada skrin di mana kita memasukkan Keadaan yang dikodkan
ke dalam tiga qubit teratas pada asasnya apa yang dilakukan litar itu adalah mengira pariti bagi keadaan asas standard
untuk dua qubit teratas serta untuk dua qubit bawah pengekodan dan ini akan mendedahkan
lokasi bit flip khususnya dalam kes ini kita akan mendapat hasil satu untuk kedua-dua semakan pariti ini dan daripada
maklumat itu kita boleh simpulkan bahawa bit tengah berbeza daripada dua yang lain jadi itu jelas yang
terbalik dan yang penting ini tidak menyebabkan keadaan runtuh jadi kita kini ada peluang untuk cuba membetulkan bit flip ini
supaya akhirnya kita mungkin boleh menyahkod dan mendapatkan keadaan asal kita semula kita akan kembali kepada pembetulan
dalam sekejap tapi pertama mari kita pertimbangkan secara ringkas kemungkinan-kemungkinan lain untuk ralat bit flip Jika sebaliknya ralat bit flip
berlaku pada qubit bawah atau kiri maka kita akan mendapat hasil satu sifar dibaca dari bawah ke atas dan sekali lagi
keadaan tidak berubah dan jika bit flip berlaku pada qubit atas maka outputnya akan menjadi
01 dan sekali lagi keadaan tidak berubah dan ngomong-ngomong jika tiada
ralat bit flip langsung maka hasil pengukuran adalah 00 dan sekali lagi keadaan keluar tidak berubah
jadi mari kita ringkaskan semua ini dalam bentuk jadual di mana kita senaraikan setiap kemungkinan keadaan yang kita perolehi daripada paling banyak satu bit flip hasil pengukuran
yang kita rujuk sebagai sindrom dalam konteks pembetulan ralat dan pembetulan yang perlu kita buat untuk mendapatkan semula
pengekodan asal jika tiada ralat sindromnya adalah 00 dan tidak perlu buat apa-apa untuk membaiki
keadaan jika qubit bawah atau paling kiri mengalami bit flip sindromnya adalah satu sifar dan pembetulan yang sesuai
adalah menggunakan gate-x pada qubit bawah atau paling kiri dan dua kes lain adalah
serupa jadi jika kita menerapkan pembetulan yang sesuai berdasarkan sindrom maka kita pasti akan mendapatkan semula
pengekodan asal dalam semua empat kes sekali lagi kita hanya mempertimbangkan kemungkinan bahawa paling banyak satu
ralat bit flip berlaku ini tidak akan berjaya dengan betul jika dua atau tiga bit terbalik dan kita juga belum mempertimbangkan
kemungkinan ralat lain kini mari kita pertimbangkan jenis ralat yang berbeza dalam tetapan kuantum bit
flip bukan satu-satunya ralat yang perlu kita risaukan sebagai contoh kita juga perlu risau tentang
ralat phase flip atau ringkasnya phase flip yang diterangkan oleh gate-Z atau setara poliZ
WEBVTT
malangnya kod pengulangan tiga-bit langsung gagal untuk mengesan phase flip contohnya andaikan kita
mengkodkan qubit menggunakan kod pengulangan 3-bit seperti sebelum ini dan ralat phase flip berlaku pada qubit tengah
kita akan mendapat keadaan yang ditunjukkan pada skrin yang adalah tepat pengekodan yang kita akan dapat jika
phase flip telah berlaku pada qubit asal sebelum kita mengkodkan dan jadi jika kita melakukan
litar yang sama seperti sebelum ini untuk cuba mengesan ralat kita akan mendapat sindrom 00 yang salah mencadangkan bahawa tiada ralat berlaku
jadi kod pengulangan 3-bit berfungsi untuk paling banyak satu ralat bit flip tapi ia gagal mengesan ralat phase flip dalam
kebenaran ia sebenarnya memburukkan keadaan dalam sesuatu erti kata kerana kini kita ada tiga kali lebih banyak qubit yang berpotensi mengalami ralat phase flip
kita telah perhatikan bahawa kod pengulangan tiga-bit langsung mengabaikan ralat phase flip jadi ia nampaknya tidak
begitu berguna untuk menangani jenis ralat ini tapi sebenarnya kita boleh mengubah suai kod pengulangan tiga-bit supaya ia
boleh mengesan ralat phase flip dan saya akan terangkan sekarang bagaimana ini boleh dilakukan ini adalah litar asal untuk
mengkodkan qubit menggunakan kod pengulangan 3-bit dan cara kita akan mengubahnya adalah sangat mudah kita hanya menggunakan
gate Hadamard pada setiap qubit pengekodan gate Hadamard mengubah keadaan sifar menjadi keadaan plus dan keadaan satu
menjadi keadaan minus jadi kesan keseluruhannya adalah kita mendapat keadaan yang ditunjukkan pada skrin di mana ket
plus-plus-plus dan ket minus-minus-minus adalah notasi singkatan untuk tensor tiga keadaan plus atau tiga keadaan minus
ralat phase flip atau dengan kata lain gate-z mengubah keadaan plus menjadi keadaan minus dan keadaan minus menjadi
keadaan plus jadi pengekodan ini berguna untuk mengesan dan membetulkan ralat phase flip dan untuk melakukan itu kita boleh
mengubah litar pengesanan ralat dari sebelumnya dengan cara berikut ini adalah litar dari sebelumnya dan apa yang akan kita lakukan adalah
hanya meletakkan gate Hadamard di kedua-dua permulaan dan hujung seperti yang ditunjukkan pada skrin
ideanya sangat mudah tiga gate Hadamard pertama mengubah keadaan plus dan minus kembali menjadi keadaan sifar dan satu yang
sama semakan pariti seperti sebelumnya berlaku dan kemudian lapisan kedua gate Hadamard membawa kita kembali kepada
pengekodan cara lain untuk memikirkan tentang ini adalah kita pada dasarnya hanya mengubah ralat phase flip menjadi ralat bit flip dengan mengkonjugat oleh operasi Hadamard
kita boleh ngomong-ngomong memudahkan litar itu sedikit litar ini di sini adalah setara sepenuhnya
dan kamu boleh semak ini sendiri jika kamu mahu jadi jika kita masukkan qubit yang dikodkan ke dalam litar ini dengan mengandaikan
tiada ralat phase flip berlaku kita mendapat sindrom 0 0 menunjukkan bahawa tiada ralat phase flip
dan jika kita ada ralat phase flip pada qubit atas katakanlah maka plus dan minus paling kanan terbalik
dan itu menghasilkan sindrom ralat yang berbeza 01 dalam kes ini yang mengenal pasti lokasi phase flip seperti
yang kita ada untuk bit flip dan kita kemudiannya boleh membetulkannya dengan menggunakan gate-z pada qubit atas dan situasi
adalah serupa untuk ralat phase flip pada mana-mana dua qubit yang lain jadi kita boleh sebenarnya mengesan dan
membetulkan sehingga satu ralat phase flip menggunakan kod ini tapi malangnya seperti yang mungkin kamu dah agak kita kini tidak lagi boleh
membetulkan ralat bit flip semua belum hilang walau bagaimanapun kerana kita sebenarnya boleh menggabungkan kedua-dua kod ini
bersama-sama untuk mendapatkan kod yang boleh membetulkan ralat bit flip dan ralat phase flip dan sebenarnya ia akan dapat
membetulkan sebarang ralat pada satu qubit kini tiba masanya untuk membincangkan kod Shore 9 qubit yang merupakan kod
pembetulan ralat Kuantum yang boleh kita perolehi dengan menggabungkan kedua-dua kod yang baru kita lihat iaitu kod pengulangan tiga-bit
yang membolehkan kita membetulkan satu ralat bit flip dan versi yang diubah suai kod itu yang membolehkan kita membetulkan satu ralat phase flip
lebih tepat lagi kod Shore 9 qubit adalah kod yang kita perolehi dengan menghubungkan kedua-dua kod ini bermakna
kita pertama menerapkan satu pengekodan yang mengkodkan satu qubit kepada tiga dan kemudian kita menerapkan pengekodan lain pada setiap
tiga qubit secara berasingan jadi kita akan mendapat sembilan qubit secara keseluruhannya kita boleh nyatakan ini dalam bentuk
rajah litar seperti berikut pertama kita akan menerapkan versi yang diubah suai kod pengulangan 3-bit
yang mengesan ralat phase flip dan kemudian kita akan mengkodkan setiap qubit yang terhasil secara bebas menggunakan kod
pengulangan 3-bit asal jadi jika kita mengecilkan litar ini sedikit untuk membuat lebih banyak ruang kita boleh
menyatakan kod itu dalam istilah yang agak berbeza dengan menggambarkan bagaimana dua keadaan asas standard untuk qubit asal kita
dikodkan dan setelah kita mengetahui ini kita boleh menentukan secara lineariti bagaimana vektor keadaan qubit sewenang-wenangnya
dikodkan jadi itulah kod Shore 9 qubit dan ideanya ialah satu kod membolehkan kita membetulkan
ralat phase flip dan kod yang lain membolehkan kita membetulkan ralat bit flip dan seperti yang akan kita lihat itu sebenarnya bermakna kita boleh
membetulkan ralat sewenang-wenangnya pada satu qubit kini mari kita lihat bagaimana kita boleh mengesan dan membetulkan ralat menggunakan kod Shore 9 qubit
bermula dengan ralat bit flip yang juga dipanggil ralat-X ini adalah litar yang melakukan
pengekodan dan hanya untuk memudahkan perbincangan kita akan fikirkan sembilan qubit yang kita dapat daripada kod ini sebagai
dikumpulkan kepada tiga blok tiga qubit di mana setiap blok mewakili pengekodan yang kita dapat dengan menerapkan
langkah pengekodan kedua iaitu kod pengulangan 3-bit biasa yang dipanggil kod dalaman dalam
konteks ini manakala kod luaran adalah kod yang digunakan untuk langkah pengekodan pertama yang dalam kes ini adalah versi yang diubah suai
kod pengulangan tiga-bit yang berfungsi untuk ralat phase flip untuk membetulkan ralat bit flip kita boleh
hanya merawat setiap blok secara berasingan setiap blok adalah pengekodan qubit menggunakan kod pengulangan tiga-bit
dan kod itu melindungi daripada ralat bit flip andaikan pertama ralat-X berlaku pada mana-mana satu qubit
seperti qubit tengah dalam blok tengah jika kita memeriksa setiap blok secara bebas untuk ralat bit flip dan
membetulkan sebarang ralat yang kita jumpa maka ralat ini akan diperbetulkan dan pengekodan asal akan
dipulihkan sebenarnya kita boleh ada berbilang ralat-X dan masih membetulkan semuanya dengan cara ini asalkan ralat-ralat itu berada dalam
blok berasingan jika kita ada dua atau tiga ralat-x dalam satu blok kita akan dalam masalah tapi
selagi ada paling banyak satu ralat-X setiap blok kod dalaman akan menangkapnya dan kita akan dapat memulihkan
keadaan yang dikodkan asal jadi membetulkan ralat bit flip adalah perkara yang agak mudah untuk kod ini kita juga perlu mempertimbangkan ralat phase flip
atau dengan kata lain ralat-Z kali ini tidak begitu jelas apa yang perlu kita lakukan kerana kod luaran adalah yang
membetulkan ralat phase flip tapi kita tidak boleh mengesan dan membetulkannya secara langsung kerana kod dalaman entah bagaimana
WEBVTT
menyekat tapi kita akan lihat cara melakukan ini tidak lama lagi untuk lebih memahami cara ralat-X dan ralat-Z
berfungsi dan kesan yang mereka ada dalam litar kuantum adalah berguna untuk memerhatikan beberapa hubungan mudah antara ralat-ralat ini dan gate
controlled-NOT dan ini juga akan berguna dalam pelajaran berikutnya pertama mari mulakan dengan ralat-X
atau gate-X dan cara ia berkaitan dengan gate controlled-NOT jika kita menerapkan gate-X pada
qubit target bagi satu CNOT dan kemudian menerapkan CNOT itu maka itu bersamaan dengan menukar urutan dan melakukan CNOT
dahulu sebaliknya jika kita menerapkan gate-x pada qubit kawalan bagi satu CNOT dan kemudian menerapkan CNOT kita tidak boleh hanya
menukar urutan tapi sebaliknya kita perlu menerapkan gate-x pada kedua-dua qubit dan kamu boleh semak semua hubungan ini pada
diri sendiri jika kamu mahu dengan memikirkan apa yang berlaku pada keadaan asas standard sebagai contoh situasi adalah serupa untuk ralat-Z
kecuali bahawa peranan qubit kawalan dan target bertukar khususnya jika kita melakukan
gate-z pada qubit kawalan bagi satu CNOT dan kemudian melakukan CNOT maka itu mempunyai kesan yang sama seperti melakukan
gate-z selepas CNOT tapi jika kita melakukan gate-z pada qubit target sebagai gantinya maka itu adalah
bersamaan dengan melakukan CNOT dahulu dan kemudian menerapkan gate-z pada kedua-dua qubit dan akhirnya semua
hubungan ini adalah simetri dalam erti kata kita selalu boleh menukar urutan gate pada kedua-dua belah setiap persamaan
yang bersamaan dengan mengambil songsangan atau konjugat transpose kedua-dua belah memandangkan gate-x, gate-z dan gate controlled-NOT
semuanya merupakan songsangan mereka sendiri kini mari kita pertimbangkan ralat phase flip dan cara kita boleh mengesan dan membetulkan
mereka menggunakan kod Shore 9 qubit ini adalah litar pengekodan kita dan kita akan terus memikirkan sembilan
qubit yang digunakan dalam pengekodan sebagai dikumpulkan kepada tiga blok tiga qubit andaikan ralat-z berlaku pada
mana-mana satu qubit seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini menggunakan apa yang baru kita perhatikan tentang gate-Z
dan gate controlled-NOT itu bersamaan dengan dua ralat-Z sebelum CNOT satu pada
qubit kawalan dan satu pada qubit target dan ralat-ralat ini kebetulan bertukar dengan CNOT yang lain dalam blok jadi kita boleh
menukar urutan dan ini adalah yang kita perolehi ralat-Z yang lebih rendah tidak melakukan apa-apa kerana ia bertindak pada keadaan sifar
dan kita boleh menggeser semua yang lain dan mendapat rajah ini jadi apa yang kita dapati adalah bahawa ralat-Z di suatu tempat dalam
blok tengah bersamaan dengan ralat-Z yang berlaku pada qubit tengah sebelum fasa pengekodan kedua dan
kamu boleh menggunakan alasan yang sama untuk ralat-Z pada mana-mana qubit phase flip pada mana-mana qubit dalam satu blok
bersamaan dengan phase flip pada qubit yang berkaitan sebelum pengekodan dalaman dan itu sebenarnya agak mudah dan intuitif jika kamu
fikirkan bagaimana ralat-Z mempengaruhi kod pengulangan tiga-bit jadi satu pilihan untuk menangani ralat-Z
adalah menyahkodkan kod dalaman dan kemudian mengesan dan membetulkan ralat-Z menggunakan kod luaran iaitu versi yang diubah suai
kod pengulangan 3-bit yang boleh membetulkan ralat-Z jadi itu membetulkan ralat-Z kita dan
kita boleh mengkod semula dengan kod dalaman jika kita mahu melakukan itu kita juga boleh membetulkan ralat-Z dalam
keadaan sedia ada jadi untuk bercakap tanpa penyahkodan dan kemudian pengkodan semula dan ia agak mudah tapi untuk menjelaskan cara kita
boleh melakukan itu kita perlukan sedikit lebih banyak ruang andaikan kita menyahkodkan kod dalaman
dan kemudian kita mengira sindrom untuk kod luaran menggunakan kaedah yang sama seperti sebelumnya di mana kita hanya melibatkan tiga qubit dari kod luaran dan
kemudian kita mengkodkan semula nah kita boleh memudahkan semua CNOT ini sedikit dan sebenarnya
kita boleh menggunakan hubungan antara gate NOT dan gate controlled-NOT yang baru kita perhatikan sebentar tadi untuk membantu dengan tugasan itu
dan dengan melakukan ini kita boleh jimatkan empat CNOT dan ini adalah litar yang kita perolehi jika ralat-Z telah berlaku pada salah satu
qubit apa yang sindrom memberitahu kita sekarang bukan qubit mana yang mengalami ralat-Z tapi blok mana ralat-Z itu
berlaku tapi tak apa kerana kita tahu bahawa tidak kira qubit mana dalam satu blok yang mengalami ralat-Z
kesannya adalah sama untuk ketiga-tiga qubit dalam blok itu dan jadi kita sebenarnya boleh membetulkan ralat-Z dengan menerapkan gate-z pada mana-mana
qubit dalam blok tersebut ini ngomong-ngomong adalah contoh apa yang dipanggil degenerasi dalam sebuah kod
pembetulan ralat di mana kita tidak mengenal pasti secara unik ralat yang diberikan tapi kita boleh membetulkannya jua akhirnya katakanlah kedua-dua
bit flip dan ralat phase flip berlaku mungkin pada qubit yang sama sebagai contoh katakanlah
bit flip dan ralat phase flip berlaku pada qubit ini di sini ternyata ralat-ralat ini boleh
dikesan dan dibetulkan secara bebas dan sebenarnya tidak kira sama ada kita membetulkan setiap blok untuk bit
flip dahulu dan kemudian membetulkan phase flip atau jika kita melakukannya cara lain untuk melihat ini mari kita pertama perhatikan bahawa
urutan ralat-ralat ini tidak penting jadi kita boleh menukarkannya jika kita mahu sebabnya bukan kerana
X dan Z bertukar kerana mereka tidak X kali Z sama dengan negatif Z kali X tapi
faktor negatif 1 tidak mempunyai kesan dalam situasi ini kerana ia adalah fasa global kita kini boleh menggerakkan ralat-Z seperti
sebelumnya dan pada ketika ini jelas bahawa jika kita membetulkan setiap blok untuk ralat-X dahulu dan kemudian kita membetulkan
untuk ralat-Z kita kemudiannya akan membetulkan kedua-dua ralat sebagai alternatif jika atas sebab tertentu
kita memutuskan untuk membetulkan ralat-Z dahulu kita boleh melakukan itu dan ralat-X tidak mempunyai kesan langsung dalam proses itu
itu mesti benar kerana nombor satu ralat-X bertukar dengan setiap gate tunggal dalam litar yang mengira
sindrom untuk kod luaran dan nombor dua urutan antara ralat-X dan gate-z yang kita gunakan untuk membuat
pembetulan tidak penting seperti yang kita hujahkan apabila gate-z adalah ralat jadi itu membolehkan pembetulan ralat-Z
dan kita kemudiannya boleh membetulkan setiap blok untuk menghapuskan ralat-X jadi apa yang kita hujahkan adalah bahawa kita boleh
membetulkan ralat-X, ralat-Z atau kedua-duanya pada mana-mana satu qubit menggunakan kod ini
sebenarnya kita boleh membetulkan lebih banyak ralat daripada itu seperti berbilang ralat-X selagi mereka jatuh ke blok yang berbeza
atau berbilang ralat-Z selagi paling banyak satu blok mendapat bilangan ganjil daripadanya tapi ke hadapan apa yang paling relevan
adalah bahawa kita boleh membetulkan ralat-X, ralat-Z atau kedua-duanya pada mana-mana satu qubit dan dalam bahagian terakhir pelajaran
kita akan lihat bagaimana ini sebenarnya cukup untuk menyimpulkan bahawa kod ini boleh membetulkan sebarang ralat pada mana-mana satu
qubit sebelum kita beralih ke bahagian terakhir pelajaran di mana kita akan mempertimbangkan ralat Kuantum sewenang-wenangnya kita akan secara ringkas
mempertimbangkan prestasi kod Shore 9 qubit apabila ralat yang diwakili oleh matriks Pauli berlaku secara rawak pada
WEBVTT
qubit untuk lebih konkrit mari kita pertimbangkan model hingar mudah di mana ralat berlaku secara bebas pada qubit
dengan setiap qubit mengalami ralat dengan kebarangkalian p dan tanpa korelasi antara ralat pada qubit yang berbeza
senario paling buruk untuk kod Shore 9 qubit ialah ralat-y atau dengan kata lain kedua-dua ralat-X dan ralat-Z
berlaku pada setiap qubit yang terjejas dan kita akan anggap senario paling buruk ini semata-mata untuk mendapatkan batas
terhadap prestasi kod tapi kamu juga boleh mempertimbangkan sebagai contoh bahawa tiga ralat Pauli adalah sama rata
mungkin kini katakanlah Q adalah qubit dalam beberapa keadaan tertentu yang kita ingin lindungi daripada ralat dan bayangkan bahawa
kita ada pilihan untuk menggunakan kod Shore 9 qubit adakah kita patut gunakannya nah jawapannya tidak semestinya
ya kerana jika terlalu banyak hingar atau dengan kata lain p terlalu besar menggunakan kod Shore sebenarnya boleh memburukkan keadaan
seperti yang kita ada untuk kod pengulangan apabila p lebih besar daripada separuh tapi jika p cukup kecil maka
jawapannya adalah ya kita patut gunakan kod jadi mari kita lihat mengapa ini berlaku dan apa maksudnya untuk p terlalu besar atau cukup kecil
untuk kod ini kod Shore boleh membetulkan sebarang ralat Pauli pada satu qubit dan dalam senario paling buruk
di mana ralat Pauli adalah ralat-y ini bermakna bahawa kod itu berjaya melindungi Q dengan kebarangkalian yang diberikan oleh
ungkapan yang ditunjukkan pada skrin khususnya kod berjaya apabila tiada ralat dan itu berlaku
dengan kebarangkalian 1 tolak p kuasa 9 kerana ada sembilan qubit yang masing-masing mesti tidak terjejas dan ia berjaya apabila ada
tepat satu ralat dan memandangkan ada sembilan qubit berbeza yang mungkin terjejas ini berlaku dengan kebarangkalian 9 kali P kali 1 tolak p kuasa 8
sebaliknya jika kita tidak repot-repot menggunakan kod satu qubit kita sahaja tidak akan terjejas oleh ralat dengan
kebarangkalian satu tolak P jadi kod hanya membantu apabila kebarangkalian pertama lebih besar daripada yang kedua
kerana ungkapan-ungkapan ini mewakili kebarangkalian kejayaan kita dalam dua kes apabila kita menggunakan kod dan apabila kita
tidak ini adalah plot dua fungsi ini untuk nilai p yang kecil dan kita dapati titik pulang modal berlaku pada
lebih kurang 3 dan tiga per empat peratus jadi jika p lebih kecil daripada nilai ini maka kod itu
membantu pada titik pulang modal kebarangkalian adalah sama jadi kita hanya membuang masa bersama 8 qubit jika
kita menggunakan kod tapi selainnya tidak ada bahaya padanya dan melebihi titik itu kita pastinya tidak sepatutnya menggunakan kod ini
kerana ia sebenarnya meningkatkan peluang ralat pada qubit yang dikodkan yang kita biasanya rujuk sebagai
qubit logik dalam konteks ini dan itu berlaku semata-mata kerana peluang dua atau lebih ralat pada sembilan qubit adalah
lebih besar daripada peluang satu ralat pada satu qubit untuk nilai p dalam julat ini 3 dan tiga per empat peratus mungkin nampak tidak
bagus terutamanya berbanding 50% yang merupakan titik pulang modal yang setara untuk kod pengulangan tiga-bit untuk
maklumat klasikal tapi lebih susah untuk melindungi maklumat kuantum dan selain itu walaupun
kod ini merupakan penemuan yang cemerlang sebagai kod pembetulan ralat Kuantum yang pertama sekali dan ia sangat bagus untuk tujuan pedagogi hakikatnya
ia bukan kod yang bagus dalam istilah praktikal setakat ini kita telah mempertimbangkan ralat-X
dan ralat-Z dalam konteks kod Shore 9 qubit kini mari kita pertimbangkan ralat sewenang-wenangnya
bermula pertama dengan ralat unitari contohnya ralat sedemikian boleh berkaitan dengan putaran kecil
bagi bola Bloch yang mungkin mewakili ralat yang ditanggung oleh gate yang tidak sempurna sebagai contoh
atau ia boleh menjadi mana-mana operasi unitari pada qubit dan tidak semestinya sesuatu yang hampir dengan operasi identiti
mungkin nampak seperti membetulkan ralat sedemikian adalah susah terdapat infiniti banyak kemungkinan ralat seperti
ini dan tidak dapat dibayangkan bahawa kita boleh entah bagaimana mengenal pasti dengan tepat apa ralat itu dan kemudian membatalkannya tapi kita
sebenarnya tidak perlu melakukan apa-apa yang berbeza daripada yang sudah kita bincangkan selagi kita boleh membetulkan untuk bit flip, phase flip atau kedua-duanya maka kita
sebenarnya akan berjaya dalam membetulkan ralat unitari qubit tunggal sewenang-wenangnya dan saya akan terangkan sekarang mengapa begitu
pertama seperti semua matriks 2x2 kita boleh menyatakan matriks unitari sewenang-wenangnya
yang mewakili ralat pada qubit tunggal sebagai gabungan linear empat matriks Pauli termasuk matriks identiti
dan ngomong-ngomong seperti yang mungkin kamu perhatikan saya menggunakan X, Y dan Z berhuruf besar untuk menandakan matriks Pauli bukan-identiti
dan saya akan teruskan berbuat demikian untuk seluruh siri ini itu konvensional dalam pembetulan ralat kuantum dan ia juga membuatkan
sesuatu lebih mudah dibaca dalam konteks ini juga akan berguna untuk menggunakan subskrip untuk menunjukkan qubit mana
operasi unitari qubit yang diberikan bertindak padanya jadi sebagai contoh jika kita menggunakan
konvensyen penomoran qubit Qiskit yang bermula dari qubit sifar di sebelah kanan maka kita ada ungkapan yang ditunjukkan pada skrin untuk
pelbagai operasi unitari pada qubit tunggal di mana dalam setiap kes kita meng-tensor matriks unitari dengan matriks identiti
pada setiap qubit lain jadi khususnya kita boleh menyatakan UK bermakna U diterapkan pada qubit K sebagai
gabungan linear yang sama seperti sebelumnya kecuali bahawa setiap matriks Pauli diterapkan pada qubit K kita tidak perlu repot-repot dengan
subskrip untuk identiti ngomong-ngomong pemahaman di sini adalah bahawa ini adalah identiti pada semua
qubit kini katakanlah psi adalah pengekodan 9 qubit bagi keadaan qubit jika ralat U berlaku pada
qubit k maka kita mendapat U-k kali psi yang boleh kita nyatakan sebagai gabungan linear operasi Pauli yang bertindak pada psi yang sudah tentu
hanyalah psi dalam kes identiti pada ketika ini akan berguna untuk memerhatikan bahawa matriks Pauli-Y
sama dengan i kali X kali Z jadi kita boleh membuat penggantian itu dalam
ungkapan kita jadi ralat ini telah berlaku dan kini katakanlah kita cuba membetulkannya menggunakan prosedur yang sama seperti
untuk langkah pertama adalah mengira sindrom yang dalam kes kod Shore adalah 8 bit panjangnya dua bit untuk setiap tiga kali
kita menggunakan kod dalaman bersama-sama dengan tambahan dua bit untuk kod luaran tapi tidak begitu penting kita boleh hanya fikirkannya sebagai
rentetan panjang tetap di sini adalah penerangan keadaan yang kita dapat tepat sebelum pengukuran sindrom di mana setiap
sindrom adalah lapan bit apa sahaja yang kita dapat daripada ralat Pauli yang berkaitan perhatikan pada ketika ini bahawa dua
sistem adalah berkorelasi secara umum dan ini sebenarnya adalah kunci untuk menjadikan semua ini berfungsi dengan mengukur sindrom apa yang
akan kita lakukan secara efektif adalah meruntuhkan keadaan kepada satu di mana satu daripada empat operasi Pauli telah diterapkan pada
qubit ke-K bagi psi dan kita akan tahu daripada sindrom operasi Pauli mana itu jadi kita boleh membetulkannya jika
perlu khususnya jika kita mengukur sindrom dan membuat pembetulan yang sesuai maka kita mendapat keadaan dalam
WEBVTT
bentuk yang ditunjukkan pada skrin yang secara kritikalnya adalah keadaan hasil yang kita ada pengekodan asal yang tidak rosak sebagai
faktor tensor kanan yang merupakan yang paling penting di sini dan di sebelah kiri kita ada matriks ketumpatan s yang
menggambarkan sindrom ralat rawak tapi tiada lagi korelasi dengan sistem yang kita ambil berat iaitu
yang di sebelah kanan kerana ralat telah diperbetulkan pada ketika ini kita boleh buang qubit sindrom atau tetapkan semula mereka dalam
kes kita ingin menggunakannya lagi dan itu sebenarnya cukup penting kerana inilah cara kerawakan atau entropi
yang dihasilkan oleh ralat dikeluarkan daripada sistem dan begitulah pendiskritan Ralat berfungsi sekurang-kurangnya untuk ralat unitari
pada dasarnya dengan mengukur sindrom kita secara efektif memproyeksikan ralat kepada ralat yang diterangkan oleh
matriks Pauli pada pandangan pertama mungkin nampak terlalu bagus untuk menjadi kenyataan bahawa kita boleh membetulkan ralat unitari sewenang-wenangnya
seperti ini bahkan ralat yang kecil dan hampir tidak ketara tersendiri tapi apa yang penting untuk disedari di sini
adalah bahawa ini adalah ralat unitari pada satu qubit dan mengikut reka bentuk kod operasi qubit tunggal tidak boleh mengubah keadaan
qubit Logik yang sedang dikodkan semua yang ia boleh lakukan adalah menggerakkan keadaan keluar daripada ruang pengekodan yang sah
tapi kemudian pembetulan membawanya terus kembali ke tempatnya akhirnya mari kita pertimbangkan apa yang berlaku
apabila ralat sewenang-wenangnya bukan semestinya unitari berlaku persediaan adalah sama seperti sebelumnya
kita telah mengkodkan satu qubit kepada 9 menggunakan kod Shore dan beberapa ralat sewenang-wenangnya yang diwakili oleh saluran qubit ini
berlaku pada salah satu qubit seperti yang akan kita lihat semuanya akan berjalan dengan cara yang hampir sama
seperti yang berlaku untuk ralat unitari dan langkah pertama ke arah mengesahkan ini adalah mempertimbangkan perwakilan silang ralat kita
apa yang boleh kita lakukan sekarang adalah mengikuti alasan yang sama persis seperti untuk ralat unitari kecuali bahawa kita menerapkan alasan itu
pada matriks silang dan bukannya pada matriks unitari tunggal yang mewakili ralat
khususnya setiap matriks silang boleh dinyatakan sebagai gabungan linear matriks Pauli dan ini membolehkan kita
menyatakan tindakan ralat ini phi pada qubit ke-K mana-mana yang berlaku dalam bentuk yang ditunjukkan di sini pada
skrin semua yang kita lakukan di sini adalah mengembangkan matriks silang sebagai gabungan linear matriks Pauli
jika kita kemudian mengira dan mengukur sindrom ralat dan membetulkan sebarang ralat yang didedahkan kita akan mendapat
jenis keadaan yang serupa dengan apa yang kita ada dalam kes ralat unitari saya tidak akan melalui perinciannya ia semua agak serupa dengan kes unitari
dan juga sedikit lebih berserabut untuk dituliskan tapi dari segi konseptual ia agak
mudah difahami saya harus menyebut bahawa semua ini digeneralisasikan kepada kod pembetulan ralat Kuantum yang lain termasuk kod yang boleh membetulkan untuk ralat pada berbilang
qubit dalam kes sedemikian ralat pada berbilang qubit boleh dinyatakan sebagai gabungan linear hasil tensor matriks Pauli
dan bersepadanan dengannya pelbagai sindrom yang mungkin akan menggambarkan Pembetulan yang dilakukan pada berbilang qubit dan bukannya hanya satu
qubit tapi idea asasnya adalah sama sekali lagi dengan mengukur sindrom
kita secara efektif memproyeksikan atau meruntuhkan ralat kepada set diskrit kemungkinan yang diwakili oleh hasil tensor
matriks Pauli dan dengan membetulkan ralat-ralat tersebut iaitu ralat Pauli kita boleh memulihkan keadaan yang dikodkan asal
sementara itu apa-apa kerawakan yang dihasilkan dalam proses itu dipindahkan ke dalam qubit sindrom yang kemudiannya boleh kita
buang atau tetapkan semula yang sangat penting kerana begitulah entropi yang dihasilkan oleh ralat dan pengukuran sindrom
dikeluarkan daripada sistem dan itulah penghujung pelajaran di mana kita telah melihat buat pertama kali
pembetulan ralat Kuantum termasuk kod Shore 9 qubit dan pendiskritan Ralat saya harap kamu akan menyertai saya untuk
pelajaran seterusnya di mana kita akan membincangkan formalisme stabilizer yang memberikan kita alat yang berkuasa untuk menggambarkan dan
menganalisis kelas kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang besar dan menarik termasuk yang merupakan calon yang menjanjikan untuk
komputer kuantum sebenar selamat tinggal sehingga ketemu lagi